net zero now we hear that phrase from
political and business leaders every day
it means reducing carbon emissions by as
much as possible and then offsetting the
rest and while a growing number of
companies have set targets to reach net
zero by 2050
fewer of them have released detailed
plans
so emily to you first of all the
government's asked companies to
voluntarily release their net zero plans
i think particularly they want to do it
ahead of cop but do you think it should
be mandatory
well i certainly think it's incredibly
important i mean first of all let's say
it's fantastic that uh increasing number
of businesses are starting to recognize
the importance of putting in place net
zero targets but then also about trying
to work out how they're going to
actually achieve those with actual
detailed plans from today because we
need action today and we need to
understand what what can be done today
rather than off in the distance uh or
from the distant future so i do think
it's really important that businesses
you know do recognize the challenge and
then respond to it
well yes and it's interesting to say an
increasing number because the wwf
released some details that said that
only 19
major uk companies they say there we go
have uh published a detailed action plan
for reaching net zero so dan if you do
say force all companies to release a
plan do you also need that audited in
some way do you need the plans to be
seen to be credible and also for any
progress to be
to be monitored
well there are exceptions to every rule
of course for the moment companies
aren't doing enough and i agree with
emily it's great to see that so many
companies are taking it seriously but a
lot of companies are still indulging in
in green wash frankly so
you really can't rely on an industry to
police itself or investors to police
that industry either and that's why what
government says that cop 26 is going to
be so
important because they need to level the
playing field they need to be clear
on what we need to do next and it is
time for action and not words
so sorry dan you want the government to
sort of lay out parameters for
businesses do you is that is that what
you're calling on from them i think
governments in general yeah i wouldn't
even just say it's just a uk government
thing this is a global uh challenge but
i think uk government has a strong role
to play as we're hosting uh cop 26 and i
would like to see them go much much
further than they have done before in
terms of being clear on net zero and
what businesses particularly energy
intensive industries need to do next
well yes and there's a point there isn't
there um emily that different businesses
have very different needs in terms of
reaching net zero i think cambridge
university set out plans to reach net
zero by 2038 last year but that's a very
different prospect to a steel company or
an airline trying to get to net zero
oh absolutely so each different sector
is going to have its own his own
challenges i think one of the really
critical things though and you mentioned
a moment ago is that the need within
that net zero to do everything that you
can as a business to reduce your
emissions and leave offsetting really to
those aspects that absolutely cannot be
reduced so one example would be for
example in terms of business travel um
you know if everyone was just saying oh
we're going to offset all our business
travel continue as normal
then we simply wouldn't have enough
offsets to go around
businesses need to be looking at how
they can cut reduce their emissions
travel less we're all doing it but you
know many business interactions
virtually instead um
at the moment because of the pandemic
that needs to be ingrained in terms of
normal business action that's just one
of a myriad of examples where the first
thing ought to be cutting our emissions
and then reserving offsetting only for
those things that really cannot be cut
so that's what business can do and going
back down to what you think governments
should do you talked about them setting
out frameworks what about also making
clear what their priorities are in the
future whether it's investing in green
hydrogen or green steel or carbon
capture does that make a difference to
businesses in knowing how to go about
making their own plans
it does and frankly there are a huge
amount of technologies on the table uh
and that's useful but it actually has
become
less productive i would say there's more
options now than needed and some work
better than others so i think a more
focused approach i think if you're a
fan of renewables like i am you would
actually say that maybe things like
carbon capture uh and storage and green
hydrogen a little way off and we should
be focusing on focusing on the now
technologies like batteries uh wind and
solar and in terms of
the energy intensive stuff maybe we need
to have a really hard discussion as
consumers as people who consume about do
we need to consume as much steel glass
paper etc and i think that's the big
question that we should all be asking
ourselves